when we analyzed a one-dimensional
elastic collision in in any frame and we
had a velocity v1 initial and v2 initial
that we saw that we could reduce this is
a one-dimensional elastic collision we
could reduce our and we always have the
energy condition and the momentum
condition but when we combine the energy
momentum together we found the following
idea that the relative velocity v1 -
which we call the relative velocity
initial was just equal to the final
relative velocity the statement there
was that v1 initial minus v2 initial is
equal to minus the one final minus v2
final and we call this the energy
momentum relation for our classical
mechanics and then we could combine that
with our conservation of energy law
conservation of momentum and we've got a
linear system of equations that is much
easier to solve than the quadratic
system now what I'd like to show is that
this concept of relative velocity that
the v1 to relative velocity is
independent of the choice of reference
frame
and so if we want to analyze a collision
in any other reference frame then we
always can keep this result so now let's
look at that so again let's imagine that
we have two particles where we have
particle 1 and particle 2 we have some
origin R 1 and R 2 and now we want to
choose another reference ring so suppose
that we pick a second reference frame
which has maybe some origin over here
and we have the vectors our 1 prime and
R 2 prime and the relative vector from
the center of one reference frame to the
center of the other reference frame so
what we have are the two conditions that
R 1 is equal to capital R plus R 1 prime
R 1 is capital R plus R 1 prime R 2 is
capital R plus R 2 Prime and now if we
subtract these two equations we have R 1
minus R 2 equals R 1 prime minus R 2
prime and this shows us that the
relative position vectors and let's draw
that are this one from 2 to 1 and even
in our diagram we can see that the
vector from 2 to 1 does not depend on
the choice of reference frame and even
more importantly when we differentiate
we get that V 1 minus V 2 is equal to V
1 prime minus V 2 Prime and that becomes
our statement that the relative velocity
vector is independent of the choice of
reference frame